[Music]
Hey it's me, Destin. Welcome
to Smarter Every Day.
So a few years ago I messed up
and put a video of me playing
with my chicken on the Internet,
and now everybody says "Hey,
aren't you the chicken man?"
...his head stays rock
solid in one position.
And I'm cool with being the chicken man,
but I think there's a lot
cooler things I can be,
like, uh... I don't know. Let's
play with fire, what about that?
So today we're gonna learn about vorticity.
Vorticity is the circulation
in a confined area defi--
divided by that area.
So today we've made a fire tornado.
I guess I should put safety glasses
on to make this official science.
We've made a fire tornado
by restricting the airflow
to the flame, except
through a certain area.
Now, when I turn the vorticity up
by increasing circulation
with this vacuum cleaner,
we're going to start a chain of events.
The fire tornado will set
off a trigger on the rifle,
and the rifle will fire and
light these matches over here.
Once it lights the matches, the
gunpowder will go up and light a rocket,
and well, uh... you'll see the rest.
So let's check it out.
[Vacuum engine running]
[Sizzling]
[Loud sizzling]
[Slight sizzling]
[Sizzling intensifies]
[Periodic crackling]
That's a pretty good way
to light a bonfire.
So anyway, I was thinking about maybe
another name instead of chicken man.
How about pyrodynamicist?
What do you think about that?
[Chicken clucking]
What do you think about that, Claire?
Cool with that?
[Loud sizzling]
Anyway, you're getting smarter every day.
Have a good one.
[Music]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.